this is tamar hussein reading for
reviewer heidi kemps
scarlet nexus is a fun action game with
a great atmosphere and appealing cast of
characters
carrying an increasingly ridiculous
story to its not so triumphant
conclusion
it takes us to a world where humans have
developed psionic powers and the ability
to connect their mind to each other
this has dramatically transformed life
as we know it allowing for a new era of
connected consciousness
and advanced technology however things
are all sunshine and roses for humanity
the populace lives in fear of the others
grotesque brain consuming monsters that
randomly emerge from a mysterious belt
that surrounds the planet their
destructive impulses have rendered many
areas
uninhabitable forcing humans to
congregate in cities under the
protection of the other suppression
force
an army of elite psionics trained to
handle other attacks
yuito and kasane are two fresh-faced
recruits to the osf
and they find their skills quickly put
to the test during attacks
when a mission goes awry they will be
forced to take sides and fight to expose
disturbing truths lying under the
surface
the setting of scarlet nexus is an
intriguing mix of cyberpunk imagery
dystopian society
and pure sci-fi that captures your
attention immediately
you get the feeling from the get-go that
something's off about everything that's
going on
which only increases when you first lay
eyes on the others
horrendous aberrations that mix familiar
organic and inorganic objects into
monsters that move like living creatures
but feel disconcertingly unnatural
additionally the cutscenes are primarily
presented in the form of comic style
steel panels
giving the game the distinct feel of a
high-stakes episodic manga
you're a nasty one it's slick and
distinct
which gives scarlet nexus a lot of
personality you begin the game by
choosing either yuito or kasane
as your primary playable character yuito
is a fairly standard action game
swordsman while kasane is more of a
technical fighter with her ranged
daggers
both characters have combos jumping
strikes dodges the usual array of 3d
combat maneuvers
however they also have the ability to
use psychokinetic powers
introducing an additional unique element
to combat by holding the trigger they
can grab
a background object and slam it directly
into a foe
potentially catching an enemy off guard
and opening them up for further combo
attacks
combat doesn't feel exceptionally good
initially it's a little flowy and
disjointed especially when playing as
kasane
chaining attacks together in particular
can be hard on more resilient foes in
the early stages but it quickly improves
with the addition of the sas
a system where your playable character
can connect their brains to other squad
members and temporarily make use of
their powers
hook up with hanabi and she'll give you
pyrokinetic fire slashes that can set
enemies ablaze
borrow kagero's invincibilities to hide
from aggressive foes and you can perform
sneak attacks
utilize tsugumi's clairvoyance and
you'll be able to spot hidden enemies
and weak points
using these skills transforms combat
from a fairly standard affair to
something much more interesting
as certain abilities will be
particularly advantageous in given
situations
but you also have to learn to manage
these skills as they're all on cooldown
timers
even more combat augmentations open up
the further you go into the game
as you level up you can fill out nodes
in your brain map which unlocks special
skills that grant new offensive and
defensive capabilities to utilize in
battle
you'll also learn brain drive a super
powered mode that activates after
filling a gauge that increases your
damage output and combo ability
finally there's the brain field an
absurdly powerful but extremely risky
state that puts your psychokinesis into
overdrive and lets you deal massive
damage
but can kill you if you stay in it for
too long more mechanics get added to the
mix as well
guard meters are introduced using the
right skills and attacks you can break
them down to render enemies helpless and
perform devastating brain crush attacks
for bonus loot
unique objects also appear in the
environments that allow you to perform
elaborate and immensely satisfying qte
powered psychokinesis attacks
like pounding an other into the ground
with a marble statue or running over a
line of enemies with a runaway train
and by establishing a good rapport with
your teammates you unlock the full
potential of their abilities as well as
new options like follow-up attacks on
downed foes outside of the story
missions needed to progress
you can revisit already explored areas
for experience and side quests
side quests are under standard issue
kill enemy x or collect imz
missions sometimes with additional
requirements like defeating foes with a
certain
sas power they don't add much to the
game in terms of story or world building
making their role that of an excuse to
revisit areas to farm experience and
items
collecting enemy drops and environmental
data is important however
as you can trade those items at the
store for exclusive weapons upgrade
plugins and most importantly items to
give to your teammates during story
breaks
giving your crew things that they like
raises their affection for you unlocking
bond episodes
where you can hang out and learn more
about their individual quirks and
backstories
over here as their bond levels raise
you'll have access to improved sas
functionality and additional
attack and defensive options they'll
also use their presence to decorate your
team base which is a nice visual touch
bond episodes range in tone from the
completely ridiculous to the dead
serious character drama
but no matter what you wind up seeing
you'll come out of it appreciating your
in-game teammates even more
it's a good thing that the combat and
the character interactions of scarlet
nexus
are fun because its story is a train
wreck what starts as an intriguing
sci-fi tale of super-powered youths
being used to fight hideous creatures by
a shadowy government
gets completely derailed after a few
chapters becoming a hodgepodge of
increasingly bizarre plot twists and
inexplicable character actions
what's going on why would you do
something like that while you get
different perspectives and different
progression depending on whether you
choose yuito or kasani as your lead
you'll still experience the same what
the f was that nonsense events
while i won't get into spoiler territory
a good example of how frustrating the
plot can get is realizing that most of
the mid game conflict could easily be
resolved if everyone would just sit down
and talk about what's going on
something that yuito repeatedly asked to
do instead of trying to kill each other
what's even more befuddling is that some
of the characters still ask to hang out
with your lead whilst this stuff is
going on making for a bizarre disconnect
between narrative and characterization
even once all that is resolved there are
still numerous plot threats that become
incredibly flimsy when you give them
deeper thought but as ridiculous as the
story wound up being
i was interested in seeing how much more
utterly bunkers it could get throughout
so i guess that's something in its favor
even though the plot devolves into a
trope filled sludge pool by the end
i don't feel like scarlet nexus was a
waste of time yes the excitement of
combat begins to taper off towards the
end of scarlet nexus's 20-odd hour run
time
and the areas in the final stretch of
the game feel overly long
but i had a good deal of fun mixing up
my sas abilities
crushing enemies in my brain field and
watching my team have a video game
tournament at our base to settle an
argument over living space boundaries
it might not be a new pinnacle of action
game storytelling
but scarlet nexus is still plenty of fun
in the right places
do you need help
that's a big place
it was a good attack